the UN Sudan Envoy says the country's
warring generals have agreed to send
representatives to talks possibly in
Saudi Arabia Volker perthus was speaking
to the Associated Press but he also
warned there are challenges to overcome
before any negotiations can begin but
the fighting between Sudan's Army and
the paramilitary rapid support forces
has now gone on for more than three
weeks Monday was another day of
airstrikes and explosions despite a
shaky ceasefire the un's warning the
humanitarian crisis in the country is
turning into a full-blown catastrophe
even Morgan reports from Khartoum
Sudanese Army fighter jets flying over
Bahrain and East Nile in Sudan's capital
hartum targeting positions of the
paramilitary rapid support forces
residents of bahri in the northern part
of the capital say a fuel tanker
belonging to the rapid support forces
was hit leaving plumes of dark smoke as
heavy gun battle between the two sides
raged on for a third week other parts of
the capital also witnessed intense
fighting between the two sides
Hiba is too frightened to leave her
apartment in Hartung
we hear the sounds of artillery falling
in the street we are traumatized every
time we hear the fighting we feel like
we will die
the family is running out of basic
supplies
the rapid support forces are stationed
in front of our home and they won't
allow us to fix the electricity pole
there is no electricity and no water
the UN says the scale and speed of
what's unfolding is unprecedented in
Sudan It also says the humanitarian
crisis is at a Breaking Point
the head of the army General Abdel
fattah al-burhan has agreed to extend a
faltering ceasefire allowing civilians
to leave and Aid to be delivered
[Applause]
the paramilitary group the rapid support
forces have also agreed to the temporary
truths
but on the ground fighting continues
including in Khartoum and its Twin City
under man
local communities in hartum warrant
people to stay at home amidst airstrikes
and artillery fire Millions still remain
in the capital taking opportunities of
brief lulls to go and get basic
necessities where possible those who can
make their way out of the capital have
already left
evacuees in Port Sudan say they feel a
sense of shock at the sudden spiral into
Civil War many have lived and worked in
Sudan for decades
Sudan is living through a moment of real
terror I'm talking about dead bodies on
the streets we smelled the dead bodies
as we were coming to Khartoum the firing
the shelling Sudan is seriously in a
state of real war
we hope God brings peace to everyone in
Sudan we are Sudanese people residing in
the U.S people should not think that
Sudan has been destroyed no things have
happened but we wish to stay strong
this group of somalis arrived in
Mogadishu from Port Sudan
um
I am pleased that I have finally arrived
in my country however what we have been
through is unusual and hard to describe
but I'm grateful for the opportunity to
survive
but for millions of Sudanese there is
nowhere to go they're trapped by
fighting in a country the U.N says is
falling apart Hebrew Morgan Al Jazeera
Khartoum in Chad more than 20 000 people
have already crossed the border to seek
Refuge they're making the dangerous
Journey from Sudan on donkeys and by
foot the conflict is also affecting the
residents of Chad with the flow of goods
being disrupted causing food prices to
rise Ahmed Idris reports from tandalty
Westar four on the suddenly side of the
border with Chad
right behind me is the local police
station here in tandalte it is deserted
completely deserted and the lock-in key
and it looks like they hurriedly left
this place when fighting broke out in
Sudan over here is the signboard
announcing the presence of the police
station it's constructed by the United
Nations mission in Darfur as implemented
by the Islamic relief agency many of the
residents who fled the town of tandelte
after violence broke out we understand
that a lot of houses have been burned
down our security forces took to their
Hills and crossed over along with
civilians over there is the riverbed the
dry riverbed which is a crossing point
for people who live in this town and now
found themselves inside Chad now a lot
of people are moving away from this area
simply because they feel that it's no
longer safe to be here now over there
also is the towns court house it's also
under lock and key like many other
government establishments here
internality simply because people don't
believe they are safe in this community
if you look at the streets everything
every way is empty except for occasional
people one or two people who come and
check on their belongings their houses
take a bath probably and then flee
across the dried riverbed into child
despite the hardship they prefer living
in Open Spaces exposed to the elements
and of course despite the fact that they
don't have enough to eat in those camps
Ahmed Idris Al Jazeera from standard
inside therefore westafo region of Sudan